bonjour nous sommes aujourd'hui à paris
exceptionnellement chez un yvelinois
hervé this qui nous reçoit dans son
laboratoire à l'agroparistech dans un
laboratoire de l'inra en fait les gens
vous connaissent enfin le grand public
on va dire surtout grâce à la cuisine
moléculaire
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un point
justement sur cette cuisine moléculaire
que les gens comprennent enfin que nous
comprenions une bonne fois pour toutes
ce qu'il en est ce qu'elle a apporté à
la cuisine actuelle
et puis après on pourra passer à autre
chose voilà alors l'idée de la cuisine
moléculaire cédé en quatre ans en 1980 à
l'écart l'idée c'est de dire je même
casserole enfin vous vous mettez une
casserole soit une plaque chauffante
vous chauffer et moi j'observe qu'il ya
80% de l'énergie qui est fichu en l'air
en hiver on y va c'est pas très grave
puis surtout c'est une facture que vous
payez 85 répond donc la cuisine
moléculaire on s'est dit on va rénover
les techniques culinaires
alors la question c'est comment les
rénove voyez par exemple si vous voulez
faire une mayonnaise
il vous prenait un fou et sa date du
moyen-âge la non vous mettez la
mayonnaise
enfin des ingrédients là dedans dans un
bol donc il sous la dent il craque tout
d'un coup minuit les jeunes et allez
vous avez la mayonnaise
donc c'est pas la peine lors on ne sait
rien c'est passé rien magique
ici par exemple voilà le jt ça il y en a
plein les labos des ustensiles comme ça
très sexy trash à une ampoule à décanter
vous avez un bouillon qui est grave dans
les tunnels précision d'habitude c'est
difficile il faut le refroidir
non là vous ne mettez ici sauf pour il
chaud vous avez le bouillon le liquide
qui est là la grèce qui est au dessus
vous ouvrez il ya le bouillon qui sort
quand la grèce arrive vous fermez vous
avez dégraisser bouillon s'est pas c'est
pas des trucs chimie que terrible là
j'en ai un autre exemple pour clarifier
souvent pour clarifier un bouillon en
bas des blancs en neige on les met dans
la casserole avec le bouillon aurait
chauffour que ça sont prises au nom mais
dont 20 chez nous avec calage là vous
mettez ça là dedans même si comparé à
une question
ça veut dire qu'on a clarifié tajine
circulent quand votre bouillon et
troubles
tabbou lyon et les chefs ils le veulent
bien clair sans parler du gras le grath
et des ressorts d'un des maris fier
clavier c'est à dire pas de particules
pas rapide là avec sas et 15 secondes je
ne comprends pas pourquoi on cuisine
comme moyen âge alors mon plus gros
succès alors ça c'est des échecs c'est
mes échecs sexuels parce que ça n'est
pas dans tous les foyers français
ah oui il aurait fallu que toutes les
cuisines soit sait pas encore où il vend
cas où un peu mais bon ça viendra en
revanche le grand succès c'est ça voyez
le ça s'appelle un si ce n'est plus
voilà et là ça aujourd'hui il ya des
grandes enseignes de vente par
correspondance qui en vendent
ça vaut trois francs six sous et au lieu
de battre des blancs en neige vous
mettez votre blanc d'oeuf là dedans vous
avez vous donner le résultat quand ça
sert à rien de battre des blindages de
faire des mousses en fouettant état s'il
faut vous servez pas si faux quoi c'est
pas alors ça c'est un succès parce que
là j'en ai même vu dans les anneaux
elles en sont les gens sortent et
maintenant c'est la grande mode apart
on peut faire des trucs marrants on les
joue face mais je veux bien faites moi
truc mans un cocktail un cocktail
tomates au quai louis de lights pour le
printemps mais je devrais pas parce que
ça c'est de la cuisine moi je fais pas
de cuisine
non mais vous y voilà
un peu de ta matin comme ça ça va et
alors japon je sois dit cela mais je
vais reprendre un blanc d'oeuf par
exemple donc je vais je mettre un blanc
d'oeuf avec le jaune aussi mais je
n'aurais pas changé le bout le goût de
la tomate donc je vous prendre seulement
le blanc d'accord leblanc qui soit entre
nous soit dit et jaune
il est jeune claire on est d'accord je
moyenne plus jeunes dans le nez dehors
enfin non je ne prenais pas l'orangé
vous mettez tout à fait compris ensuite
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
mettre ce machin à part de fous et voilà
c'est un petit excès de régal ça fait
quand même pas compliqué donc vous vie
c'est ce truc là comme ça voilà ensuite
alors il ya des cartouches
oui alors il ya des cartouches 15 motos
non non c'est les cartouches de gaz ça
s'achète en recevant marché vous mettez
votre cartouche là dessus comme ça à
doubler de school 11 courant après comme
une cartouche de butagaz faire c'est pas
du gaz qui est close
et puis voilà ça devrait le faire alors
si vous avez mis dedans de jus de citron
du tabasco du sel du poivre
c'est délicieux oui vous avez une sorte
de cappuccino de tomates vos goûts des
mairies là on n'a rien eu de tout ça ça
va sentir mieux
ça semble hésiter m ça sent plus
séquencée au moufia sont plus là tabbat
comment ça se fait et puis c'est quand
même une texture très très agréable
enfin cesser onctueux
j'ai rien comment ça se fait que ça
sente russes apparaissent que la tomate
le goût de tomates et répartir sur
toutes les bulles comme ça fait plein
plein de bulles
il ya plein de surfaces exposées qui
vous libère le moule tabbat texture
c'est quand même plus sur l'original
ça c'est de la cuisine moléculaire on a
des outils nouveaux pour en faire autre
chose la cuisine moléculaire ça veut
dire changer les grossistes en non
simple à utiliser des ustensiles nouveau
moderne voilà qu'on n'utilisait pas
avant voilà c'est ça la cuisine
moléculaire d'accord et après on peut
faire des objets nouveaux ou anciens on
peut faire du boeuf carottes avec la
cuisine moléculaire sais pas comment
c'est au lieu de prendre une casserole
on va prendre un instant s'il qui
chauffe sans perdre 80 % d'énergie au
lieu de faire une sauce qu'on va réduire
on va faire une osmose inverse 20 on
peut et on gagne un temps fou du coup
ses soutiens la cuisson basse
température ou lave-vaisselle d'un loyer
c'est avec une brique eu l'air voulez
vous prenez une viande qui vaut 4 ans 4
euros le kilo omnium de boeuf qui est
dur
vous l'accusez à basse température
pendant vous faites la vaisselle ainsi
que de 6,3 cycle vous avez dit yang et
fondante
maintenant vous mettez la viande dans
quelque chose
ah oui bien sûr pendant vous mettez dans
une poche plastique de qualité
alimentaires amériques avec les
ingrédients les épices ce que voulait
qu'ils font et vous puisez mais c'est
merveilleux de la cuisson de lave
vaisselle par exemple pour des yeux pour
du saumon pour du foie gras pour dédé
escalope de volaille c'est sublime
parce que ça attendrissent à fait une et
puis vous avez le liquide qui apprennent
la viande non indiquées de vaisselle
l'équité dans le plastique mais on peut
pas non mais sans rire on sait pas sa
salle et si vraiment race on lave
vaisselle on est sur de vraies et bien
sûr que oui d'accord mais aujourd'hui
les gens prennent ça en rigolant parce
que l'énergie coûte pas encore très cher
et quand ça va augmenter si on peut
cuire pendant comme la vaisselle j'ai
dit oh de s'y faire moi j'ai rien allant
de toute façon je propose des choses
après les gens le font ne sont pas et
est du coup mais la preuve si vous êtes
ici aujourd'hui c'est que ça marche bien
sur wii est donc maintenant
et ça je vous dis les grandes enseignes
vendent donc ça là qui motivèrent ces
faits il faut passer à autre chose
hervé this i j'ai bien compris la
cuisine moléculaire ça y est c'est
acquis et aujourd'hui alors qu'est ce
que vous faites dans ce laboratoire a
non seulement à temps on fait la fête de
la recherche scientifique
on va de la cuisine la cuisine c'est
faire à manger elle a recherché un défi
que ça veut dire comprendre donc ici on
fait de la recherche scientifique sur
les phénomènes qui se passe en cuisine
d'ailleurs pourquoi les soufflets bon
pourquoi le bouillon de carottes points
ou de carottes pourquoi etc etc
donc je peux vous montrer comment on
fait tout ça c'est essentiellement dû
calculer les équipes lamentations
d'accord donc je crois que pour ça il
faut qu'on change d'endroit
oui on peut aller voir une pièce on va
faire de la résonance magnétique
nucléaire
la résonance magnétique nucléaire je ne
sais pas le demander mais c'est un grand
rêve
super allons-y cave etis nous voici dans
un autre endroit
comment ça s'appelle ses piètres voyez
ça c'est une résonance magnétique
nucléaire ça veut dire là dedans il ya
il y a c'est un gros est mort voilà
c'est un très très beau et bon d'accord
c'est d'abord moi j'aimerai savoir
qu'est ce que vous faites concrètement
dans ce laboratoire
voyez par exemple si tous les jours ici
là on and on avait on appris des
branches de l'arbre qui est là on les
accueille et on les a coupés comme des
rondelles de carottes
il est un fait comme un bouillon
carottes soit trop tard oui voici
aujourd'hui à temps alors ce machin à
oloron le hall fait descendre
voilà l'ère qui le dit qui qui le tient
voilà donc pour l'instant il est poussé
par de l'air alors j'ai revenir sur
cette console s'appelle une console et
là je le faire descendre
on va entendre un toc normalement voilà
maintenant le million d'arbres et dans
les normes nectar et avec cette machine
par exemple voilà cette machine voilà ce
qu'elle nous donne c'est çà et là ce que
notre métier consiste à analyser
certains aspects être et on en est un
spectre de résonance magnétique
nucléaire cela paraisse est le même que
celui des irm un nom il n'y a pas de ria
pas de radioactivité c'est juste c'est
magnétique
parce que c'est un aimant essai
nucléaire parce que on touche les atomes
de la chose qui n'a pas de radioactivité
un élément il est censé tient coi alors
non les mots il bascule les atomes les
atomes les molécules ils sont basculées
et à la vitesse ils ont tout bascule on
voit se faire par exemple ici il ya un
petit c'est de l'eau j'appelle une
résonance le pixel sommet ni sa peine ni
réseau lan ça c'est de l'eau moi je sais
c'est à 4107 l'eau et à la presse que je
cherche loi c'est à voir
ah voilà ça se passe dit césar est gelée
grosse fille et je vois de la ja il a
composé et se composait m'intéresse
beaucoup ici il ya beaucoup de composer
la ya plein de choses
ce spectre là il est il est passionnant
parce que quand on apprend à l'heure
mais pourquoi passer dans santé qu'il ya
plein de ce oui je les vois qu'ils me
connaissent c'est que ici il ya des
sucres là il ya des acides aminés les
sucreries acides aminés sont des
nutriments
ouais
il ya les pays du monde ont des gens
n'ont rien à manger si vous faites
utilisons des végétaux si au lieu de
jeter le gazon que vous couper les
branches d'arbres qui sont devant vous
vous en faites un bouillon et si vous
séparez les composent et qui sont pas
comestibles les nutriments
vous pouvez me nourrir taka danser une
façon d'aller chercher des nutriments
ailleurs habituellement à des corps donc
ça donne un champ très vaste des
possibilités dans la question c'est de
savoir à quelle vitesse ça va sortir
quand on fait un bourg d'ouilly locale
qu'est ce qu'il à sortir comment est ce
que est ce que les différents végétaux
du règne végétal vont tous nous donner
les mêmes nutriments
tout ça n'a pas été explorée il ya
beaucoup à faire alors on peut
l'analyser comme ça ensuite on peut
faire des choses un peu plus compliqué
mais déjà c'est pas mal on a et on l'a
on a en a des tas de données
intéressantes
si je veux dit un ingénieur alimentaire
tient là il ya de la leucine ou de la
lysine qui sont désactivés c'est
intéressant
moi je pourrais en faire quelque chose
dans mes plats dans ma voix là d'accord
et l'envoie qui vous parliez justement
island et des protéines qu'on trouve
dans les grillons oui alors c'est un
côté sympa 10 10 c'est bien grâce et les
insectes contiennent beaucoup de
protéines animales près
est-ce qu'on veut manger des grillons
j'en sais rien mais au moins de savoir
comme une source de protéines dans les
assiettes c'est intéressant
il ya des collègues d'agroparistech qui
font des élevages de grignan parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment actuellement oui
on peut en faire quelque chose
il ya d'ailleurs des sociétés qui
commence à en vendre d'accord mais ça
c'est une question disons d'application
et technologies nous ici on fait pas de
technologie ont fait pas on vend rien on
est un laboratoire de l'inra et l'agro
paris tech sas soit réétudié ski après
dont donné on les publient elles vont
être utilisés par l'industrie pour faire
quelque chose ou par le public non mais
écoutez aventis merci pour toutes ces
explications
et puis on va continuer la prochaine
fois vive la chimie vive la gourmandise
éclairer là et on parlera de la cuisine
note à note en profondeur d'âme à
bientôt et merci